okay hi everyone welcome to a another
wolf and language design review part of
our incremental language development
series
and we have a variety of candidate
functions to talk about today
um which I are these coming from the
function repository some are coming from
function repository some of these are
older ild suggestions
um this is kind of the switch over from
some of the old design notebooks that
we've been going through for a while to
wfr and there's some of these that are
kind of interrelated what fraction are
we through the old design notebooks have
we pretty much mined those out we have
pretty much mined them out the remaining
stuff is basically
um specialty things that we've forwarded
on to specific groups so a couple of
suggestions for import export Etc
key value scan
so we have key value map I know this was
an old older suggestion but there's
potentially some Merit to being able to
do we care I mean to me
having this is not high cognitive load
like people will understand what it does
uh
you know
it's the right I mean
I'm not sure I see the value in this
right unless it
you know right it's key value map
semicolon unless
well you know it was big
oh
I you know I get right right I guess at
the right yeah then it doesn't construct
the return expression so it
yeah and also it has the possibility of
having a return in the middle of it for
example
the skin
[Music]
yeah yeah that was the thing I couldn't
remember yeah because I so rarely used
it I would say this is probably worth
having it's easy enough to implement it
has it's not difficult to understand
what it is
seems sensible to me
it doesn't seem like it's a
you know
I can't immediately think of a fantastic
use case but I can think
when we have more out of core
kind of Association like constructs this
is going to become more interesting
yeah I was going to say the main use
cases I've come across for something
like this are you know cases where I'm
working with a large collection of data
that's in an association which is
something that happens in the units
framework for example and I want to
batch process a bunch of things that has
a side effect
um you know that's often setting
something so it's not a huge problem to
use key value map right now or to
basically no but why not have this I
mean scan is better than map if you can
use it
okay yeah
all right key select
selects that argument is a count right
select's third argument is a limit yeah
so it's
I think this is a no-brainer I think we
should have it yeah so I think the the
only potential controversy here is that
select is somewhat different than a lot
of the
I don't have level specs but there are
no level specs and associations anyway
right so I think it's pretty
uncontroversial for the the association
case
um
but that leads into the next discussion
point which is
having a select function that does have
a level spec you know we can't really
modify select at this point but if we
added a fourth argument then it'd be in
the wrong position to every other
function nope
which by the way is exactly what tree
select did
what could tree select do we have a
fourth argument it's a level spec
that is a level spec
why not just make it an optional third
argument
right because the third argument is a
count
yes but it could be and not right I mean
the three argument form is
you know if there are three arguments
the third argument is account and if
there are four arguments the third
argument is a level spec just like you
know I see one argument log the first
argument is the thing to take the log of
we haven't done this very often but
right it's it's pretty rare but it's not
without precedent I'm not sure we've
ever done this in the case of level
specs that I think this would be new in
the case of level specs but let's just
understand what the utility of this is
anyway
so this is saying
I'm actually totally confused I mean in
other words this is saying
well I suppose if you want to select
it's just a map I mean I don't
understand why this isn't just it's like
cases cases you can provide a level spec
to I know to to pick things out but I
think it makes more sense in the case of
cases than it does here why
I mean I don't necessarily I don't
necessarily disagree but
um
I frequently find myself using cases
with a pattern that's just a pattern
test
when
I'm really doing is selecting
I mean I get the I guess a more
interesting question is is what is the
structure of the return right
I mean is it this is cases it's going to
be flat is Select going to mimic the
structure of the input yeah exactly
cases makes more sense because it is
just reaping so to speak
you know it's just making a final list
of results
when select could do this I mean this
select at level is apparently not doing
that but
um
which I I actually feel is a bit strange
actually I think I would right if you're
going to have level specs that aren't
an integer rap to the list you almost
have to make it flat and
I can't even wrap my brain around how it
would work if
you're mapping it like at level two and
four and then trying to maintain
structure
yeah
gives a flat list
okay
for this exact reason
I hadn't even thought of the flat list
case I mean as we discussed
I mean and by the way
I don't have a horror
of the argument order being he says of
the argument order being different if
it's giving a flat list
because it feels a little different I
mean it's different from what happens in
cases where you really are going
I mean cases gives you a flat list also
I know
that's it
um
but I mean so the default is an Infinity
comma well no it's not the default I
mean you could in order to get
level one by default
yeah right but in order to get
all the elements on level whatever it
will be Infinity comma that level comma
the level specification
okay again let's walk through this so
Rick in your examples
do you want the reaped flat list or do
you want some kind of thing where it's
in situ yeah usually just the flat list
because
for most Expressions what you would get
probably wouldn't make sense if you just
tried to preserve the structure
um
actually I I yeah
I kind of agree that this is useful
so now the question is let's look at
tree select for a second I mean what did
what happened in our discussion of tree
select that caused us
to have the arguments in the opposite
order from select
and I will point out okay followed the
argument order of Select
no we didn't of Select because it's n
but then select didn't have a level spec
right right but then our choice for
level spec is is inconsistent from every
other function that takes a level spec
that has it in the third argument
I see
so a level spec for select
I don't quite understand if you want
everything
right if you want everything here that
and then not default novel you'd either
need to say infinity or automatic or
something like that
all
one of those
but it's got to be all comma two
that'll be one possible syntax
or two comma all
now in the case of cases
are you telling me that's how it works
it's I can say
uh level
comma n
I see
I have to say the fact that
I have to say one you know comma one
comma n has always been a bit
frustrating to me in cases
yeah I mean in select it has to be in
that order
so an optional third argument
I think so
what do you guys think I'm a little
worried about this
what other functions are there in the
family like count things like that
position
right well I think those all follow
cases right those are all pattern
matching based functions
um
so if I look at
uh
right position right so position follows
cases it's expert pattern level spec Max
number
um
well count count probably doesn't take a
Max number because it's counting right
so but might still it might still okay
well it's not documented too well
um
so
yeah I mean I suppose the
um
I mean one possible out I don't know
that it's any less ugly is to have the
level spec as some sort of option yeah
I don't really believe it
or not
um
kind of like the optional third argument
um maybe it's because I'm used to tree
having an optional first argument which
is also weird
um
you know it's even more bizarre than
this because
Grace
to brace which presumably Works in cases
for the levels back
would clue you into the fact that it's
not well I don't know just select
take
is it a take spec
the thing that's in so no no it's it's a
count
right it gives you the first n elements
so it has to it has to be a
it has to be a positive integer I mean I
suppose I suppose the I mean one issue
yeah no no never mind that was a stupid
statement
um but I I'm yeah I'm pretty sure that
you know it has to be right you can't do
minus one say right yeah it wants to be
uh a non-negative integer non-negative
not the positive integer so what does
zero do oh you can put in zero if you
want to get the the empty list
I'm the best way to get an empty list
yeah well I I will say that that is the
most efficient select possible
it runs in constant time
right
um
let's see I also tend to favor the
optional third arguments I don't love
inserting a new argument in a new
position but as etai said there are
there is precedent for it it's not done
super frequently but it does make select
symmetrical with the other functions oh
yeah I'm consistent with them right and
and well I mean and then the question is
should we change tree select which is
experimental to to match select
absolutely yeah
yeah okay we only had it fourth to avoid
having to step into this
problem
so we changed this case
fine
all right let's do it
right
so these are two similar resource
functions
um that deal with selecting either
indices or positions
or the the result is either an index or
it's a position spec
how do we deal with this in nearest
don't we have a mechanism for specifying
the return structure
um
properties annotation right the
this thing cake largest uh likewise
so why aren't we doing the same thing
with select if we have an arrow property
now the problem is because select is
much more structural yeah select can
take a rule as a first argument
um
yeah it would be kind of a silly use of
Select but it is right I guess a valid
use of Select
yeah
um
okay so this is
something that finds positions
at which a particular Criterion is true
right so we're not returning the values
we're returning either the index or the
position where the criteria is true yeah
it's the select analog to finish the um
well analogy cases is to position a
select as to what
and it doesn't relate to things like
pick and so on does it I I would hope
not
pick being the miserable function that
it is
how you really feel
yeah yeah
no and nobody quite agrees on on what it
actually means I mean in sort of trivial
cases where you know list and VA and Val
have exact are identically shaped then
that we we all agree but the moment
there's any room for interpretation we
don't all agree on what it means and
we're not and then the implementation is
is then the guide and the implementation
is misery
I see it it it not only does do people
not agree but what it's implemented to
do disagrees with everyone
oh gosh
um
all right
uh
well okay so this question here
didn't we just add index cases to
diverse other functions
I don't believe we added the the index
and value and how is this related to
um
supplied supplied yeah
yeah that I mean my initial thought with
this was that it was somewhat closely
related to position largest position
smallest which we did a couple of
versions back you know this is a
slightly more
General function in terms of taking an
arbitrary
criteria well would it make sense to
have the rule syntax like nearest but it
wrap it around the uh the function being
fast to select rather than the first
argument
because you could conceivably be trying
to
selected rule but a rule would never be
a thing you want in the right in the
selector
right so you need to remember your
parentheses but uh yeah
and I think you could potentially
use supplied to give different arguments
to the test but I don't think it I don't
think Supply should affect the output or
or or no the in the in this role syntax
that we're talking about the the the
string goes on the right hand side not
the left hand side right
yes but the point that you're making
well I'm just saying I'm just saying
that means we don't have to worry about
parentheses because the Ampersand will
be on the left side of the rule
at that point
um
uh but there's also select indexed and
so on which is what supplied should deal
with
correct yeah
um yeah indexed in the sense of it takes
the index into the test yep
foreign
[Music]
functions are we going to immediately
think about if we add this
Chang remember what what we've already
added it to and I remember we've added
it to a few things recently but I I
honestly don't remember what does
anybody else remember
and some stuff with fine shortest tour I
think oh yes yes yes
well we have the triple
position cases count
if select is to position and this sorry
if select these two cases and this is
the position
that will be the equivalent to count
I don't follow that
so the triple
count position select they always go
together
again count
position cases now select is the
equivalent of cases and I think this
function we are discussing here is the
equivalent of position
yes
so the question is do we need the
equivalent of count
select count
yeah how many things
will does count by have any hope of
achieving that
or is that too convoluted
what does count by do that we have count
by
do we have a count by yeah there's
always the possibility that I'm
completely making this up
spy yeah
is a different thing okay
I agree that there's also a count here
that
I just put another one from the function
repository in the chat where
I find this useful sometimes you know I
used to find myself writing get the
positions and then take the positions
from Expressions all the time
and this just kind of combines it into
one
yes this is useful
I mean there's also just turning an
expression into its
right sparsify or whatever you want to
call it
right into its parts
this is almost like part Association
yes but with a test with a pattern test
yes
although it could have a select two it
could there could be
positioned select
especially now that's like a normal spec
well I prefer I mean Parts Association
seems better for
that
um
I don't know let's try and get a more
systematic report on all of these kind
of orthogonal cases
okay okay take a proper inventory of the
select related functions yes select
cases count
across
and their return values and what they
eat and associations and things like
that
right so okay so I'm not sure exactly
what this function does right but
um basic the basic issue I think we're
dealing with is that
um
you know by the central dogma
you know cases cannot see
the keys yep and so if you want to do
some sort of
cases that can you know contest the keys
and possibly I don't understand why
central light doesn't solve this
[Music]
um
I no I think this is the rule thing what
did we call it like position pattern
that simultaneously matches the
expression and
its position which in this case would
include the key right okay yeah that
that's yes
if we had somebody to implement the
position pattern that would be uh that
would that would be a solution
well position pattern sounds like a
special case of supplied
well no
go ahead right Supply lives in the
function functioning world in the map
world whereas position pattern lives in
the in the cases
position pattern sounds like a really
good thing to have
however key cases is a concept that's
easy to understand
right so I I
um
so maybe key case is worth having I mean
the fact is I you know occasionally
machine generated things have
complicated left hand sides in their
associations
human generative ones tend not to they
tend to be things like strings
okay
um so I'm not sure
uh
oh I see One is using this key cases and
the other is using
key select
um yeah this was just showing you know
in principle you can make key cases out
of key select with match queue
but there's some you know cases supports
for example the transformation rules in
the pattern
which select doesn't really
say I do I want to replace all of the
instances I want the association that
has all the F of x's and replace the f
of x with x
oh so this is only pattern matching
against the keys right so this in fact
is significantly less powerful than
um position
pattern and direct analog of key select
and right and well I guess well I mean
if we supported some sort of maybe this
isn't a problem right but the moment you
support
uh you know Transformations then you
risk collisions in the Keys and
you know
is is that what you want right I mean
it's certainly potentially confusing
whether or not it's
uh you know the right time to have
emerging function option by default it
would just be
take the most recent item like
Association normally does
all right in key cases
right we're pattern matching against the
keys so if we allowed
that thing to not just be a pattern but
a rule
than in the output in the result
yes so we would need emerging function
through the Collision cases
I think key case is worth having I think
it's easy to understand I think like the
other thing we just had it's kind of
cognitively easy you've got key select
why not key cases
mm-hmm
now I agree there needs to be a merging
function
if we if we allow this form
yeah that form is fairly exotic but I
don't see why we shouldn't allow it
and then if you if the keys were
actually rules you would rep in key
or hold pattern yeah whole pattern right
that's what my thought yeah just like
kind of magic rules with cases
yep right yes
all right
counts merge
so this is a uh a suggestion from a
while ago by one of our uh live stream
viewers it is a variant of counts that
allows you to specify the expected
uh
values
and give a default value
huh
in other words I don't understand I
don't understand
and if somebody puts a seven it isn't
yes
it would typically be zero and almost
almost more as important is the order of
the output matches the order of the
second argument
right I find
at least after I get accounts I have to
reorder it a lot yeah I would use this a
lot there are a few cases where I would
definitely use this yeah I don't 100
love the name that was suggested no but
oh yeah
I mean
somehow this feels like it's part of the
categorical data of family
I mean I have to say I'm not keen on
this I don't understand why the
functionality isn't first you do the the
breaking putting things into I mean the
function that takes a list
and has a set of values that are allowed
and takes everything else to be missing
that seems like a useful function this
is then wrapped around that
see what I'm saying
there should be a function that
normalizes a list by saying here are the
allowed values here's the out of range
values make the outer range values be be
whatever you specify for example trims
outliers or yeah yeah and I mean I think
you might even want
if it's numerical values
you might want a whole set of rules for
what the missing stuff does I mean this
is basically
yeah if I mean this is a useful function
if it's in a certain set
just pass it through
otherwise mystify it
might actually be the more general form
of this is maybe give a default value to
key take as an extra argument
is then you could just run counts and do
key take with your range of five or
whatever and then give an extra
last argument saying what you want the
default to be yeah except that this
isn't keyed yet I mean you could counts
yes you can
but then there's a lot of other
Association types that aren't
necessarily accounts that you'd want to
do this exact same thing with
I I'm saying I think the more General
thing to do is we just have a function
that prunes could even be called prune
possibly
that prunes something down to a certain
set
okay and if it's outside that set
another has a fixed value or it applies
a function to determine what to do with
the with the things that are outside the
fixed set so for example I would say you
know like prune or more like conform
now I'm like prune actually
[Music]
prune this list
to my set
and that would give a failure object or
something by default and then here we
have a function
that's applied to everything that isn't
in the unset
um
I kind of like this function
is it's just not just I mean I suppose a
three argument form maybe requires a bit
of thought but isn't
isn't the two argument form just delete
cases you know maybe with an
Alternatives at at yes it is
um so the case of the complement of that
oh yes you're right
um
but the idea I mean it's closer to keep
okay strictly remove them right it would
replace them with
yeah you're right
and it isn't quite prune it's some kind
of normalized type thing
yeah I like this function it needs a
better name what's up yeah a common case
would be almost an inverse of delete
missings would be insert missings or you
know yeah exactly identify outliers I
mean that's maybe a bad method but
okay so I I'm sorry but I'm
the I mean this seems like a fine
function but I'm not sure
why we want to be inserting missings
right because the missings right the
missing here is not from the
uh
right it's out of range no it's not the
dismissing in the examples that we see
in front of us the missing is not from
being out of range it's from the fact
that there are no fives in the input
that's why I was saying I think zero
would be the more common case of using
this because if you are dealing with
counts do you want something that's not
in there to be assumed to be zero
yeah oh I see
so then if you're like incrementing
values in there so you're not in uh
right so so if you if you look at the
last the input right before the bullet
point then the four which is not in the
list is just counted as one which uh I
was actually going to ask about if
that's really what we want that things
that are not in the expected set just
sort of
insert themselves into the results
without any warning
okay so there are two issues
one is
there is a value
not in the expected set
and there are no values
for a particular entry in this in the
expected set right yep
sorry is is the expectation set keys or
values
there are no keys we're not talking
about Keys it's just values
well it's keys in the output of this
particular function that's being in in
the particular function that's proposed
at the beginning of the section but
what we're dealing with here is we want
this function to operate on values it's
just a list the first argument can be
thought of just as a list or maybe it's
an association but that's
it's um
the values of the list become the keys
of the association
and I I guess that's what's kind of
confusing me there if we're expecting to
see range five but we count something 10
times is that going to leave it as is or
chop it
right the 10 would be a value
in the output yes so there's there's two
different things we're talking about the
first the counts merge function that's
proposed there started a discussion
about a more General function which
would be this prune function
and the prune function you know
or or whatever we decide to call it is I
have a list or a set of data and then I
have my expected values this counts
merge is kind of a combination of that
function and accounting function
so so how is there any relation here to
key drop
no no
I think there's a relation to key take
though mm-hmm
yeah well or is
okay key take just keeps a certain
amount of keys
he ended a little it takes a certain
list of keys yeah
but what what it doesn't do is
fill in
something with default values if it's
not in the original
set well that probably could but it is
doing it based on keys this is doing it
I mean this is so
this is the value equivalent of key take
there's also an analog to look up which
does does you know just returns values
not an association but it fills in
missing things
yes right you could do it with lookup
and thread I guess
if you have an association
I mean this is operating on a list so
for example prune
look
and look up drops the values that
weren't in the expected list so it
wouldn't match the what we have in the
notebook for accounts merge
right I mean maybe we should call this
function keep rather than prune
okay so that
there are two possibilities for what
that could give
one is a b a b which is essentially a
select
and the other is
a b failure
three failures in a row
I'm not sure it should be a failure
that's that just sounds very aggressive
or maybe it's a message yeah
or whatever I mean the default value
whatever the default value is which we
don't know
um
well we could just say the default value
is nothing
and you get that first behavior and then
right if you specify a default you get
the second
you know
it's interesting yeah as long as we're
only working on lists yeah true yeah
well I mean not the worst thing in the
world to see a nothing in something else
and if you know what happened
and then the second part is that
question of what we do if you're
expected set is a b z and we don't have
Z's there
does the first argument have to be a
list a simple flat list
well maybe not but what do we do in this
case yeah
right you can do anything other than
because it's not keys
we're not leaving a space for disease
right yeah I think if we're keeping it
structurally the same as the input
there's nowhere to insert a this didn't
occur
right this is purely a thing for
normalizing conforming
pruning
yeah so that I guess you made it
visually with lookup is that lookup will
give an exception if something is
missing this will give an exception if
something is extra
yeah yeah if something is unexpected
so that's that's basically specifying
what's allowed in the list not
necessarily that has to have all those
items right right yeah I mean I think if
for this prune function right there
can't be any special behavior now the
question is if we had this you know
counts merge or whatever function you
know what would it do in that case
or no this case is fine yeah it'll just
say zero isn't this prune just replace
except goes to nothing
yeah
yeah or or it's or or delete cases
except uh you know at at the list right
yeah but you can also do cases
alternative and then just flatten or
concatenate the results
we'd have to have Alternatives around
the acceptor yeah no I mean it's a bit
complicated I mean every function can be
expressed in terms of other functions so
the fact that it can be expressed
doesn't particularly
right and yeah but I mean how many other
functions because I think in this case
we're only talking about combining two
or three things
I know but the question is conceptually
the name prune isn't great but I think
there is the possibility of a really
good name for this
like conform but it isn't that either
well it could be keep prune to
um
if it's going to be pruned then does it
make sense to leave a bunch of
junk in the middle of August that's why
well if it's default there's nothing
there then its default is to prune
yeah but the the general function isn't
isn't really improved like a filter is
what I or a filter or a projection
almost
this case right is
the case with nothing is purely
Alternatives applied to yeah
all right we've introduced this
let's
we need to marinate it
I actually need to go fairly soon yeah
uh this is one of Rick's uh functions
that he mentioned and I think it has a
lot of Merit it's basically a
modernization of reap where instead of
getting a structured result with
positional tags that you have lost it
has a decorated Association that has the
results and then the various tags as
keys
why doesn't have like the position where
it's being so I can't know that yeah
this requires more thought I mean I
think that this is
the benefit of this doesn't matter what
the first item was that was sewn
is you can just get things by key
otherwise it read normally you would get
the lists in the order that the tags are
first seen
so you'd have to know the underlying
code what it was doing that none is the
fact that the so didn't have a second
argument is that correct yeah
it's more interesting because
well the idea of a of a reap so
where it can
give an association there is an
interesting idea but are you sure
there's no way to fit that into the
argument structure of so and reap
uh like and I mean right you could throw
none in which case how do you
distinguish that right I mean one
argument for uh so is not the same thing
as
you know it's an argument against this
okay this is an interesting idea needs
more thought and I'm trying to escape
here unfortunately
um
um oh God
I uh you know if you need to escape I
don't think there's any problem with
just saving these for the next agenda
but let's do it okay one one comment
briefly is I really like this this um
last one reap Association or whatever it
was called I I mean we we really it it
is something that has been lacking
let me understand what the point is that
the point is that you want to have tags
yes you want to use tags and sort
according to the tags
or at least know what goes with what tag
what what group goes with what tag
that's what's been missing
I didn't mean to keep you long I just
wanted no no that's the thing but I mean
I'm kind of wondering whether there's a
way
I I think I might have beat you to it
rick
yeah
chat Wars yeah
I mean you can come pretty close with re
with the three argument form but okay
right it doesn't have that outer
Association which might kind of be good
because the names result in zone are
kind of arbitrary
oh yeah the what I was showing and the
thing I chatted was
the default Behavior you have to know
what tag is being sown first to make
sense of the output
right that that's that's what I think is
is um not so great
what do you mean because because how do
you what isn't the result was the first
argument
yeah we try to evaluate what I put in
the chat the result of the evaluation is
the first argument of reap right but to
use the second argument if you don't if
you don't have a third argument in your
reap
you're just guessing so that what one
first because that tag was selling first
so you'd had you would have had to know
what the code was going to do
the underlying code
it's implementation dependent
I don't even understand what it did why
the A's and oh because that tag one oh I
see you have no idea which tag is which
right yeah so if you replace type one
with tag two and vice versa
yeah you get them in a different order
foreign
I have to admit this reap Association
makes decent sense to me although I
wouldn't bother to have that outer sewn
result Etc I think that's a mess I agree
I I don't know why I thought it was a
good idea about when I made this but it
probably should just be a list with the
result and an association of the right
still really this is different from reap
only in the sense that it is
it is getting things in an association
which makes perfect sense to me so it's
basically the same as n47 but the second
argument is wrapped in association
yeah
because that blank comma rule is weird
all right yeah that's probably what I
did in the implementation okay I like
that okay what do we do with the nun
anything we put there can potentially be
a tag is the problem yeah I know
production
oh so Reed catches both one argument and
so reap blank catches both one argument
and two arguments those which is
different from throw throw and catch
this is a good function I agree so I
think we just have to solve the problem
of what
the
I mean but by the way
how many arguments does this crazy thing
have
reap has a lot I mean it's a Pity that
there aren't like named elements here of
the reap output which is what I think
you were going for but I think at this
scale
you know the more common thing is going
to be I just want the
Stone tag so to speak
um
I'm not sure uh we need a better version
of money
what the heck do we do what does pattern
matching do when an argument is simply
not there
yeah it's I mean it basically it's a
crazy
null sequence
right well it's not literally right it
just it just it's just removed from the
yeah from the right hand side
technically that single underscore
shouldn't match it right
well maybe there could be just be two
separate associations and that would
avoid key Collision
well it isn't an association it's just
one case
yeah maybe what it is is it's a triple A
list of three things the result
go ahead the unnamed
unknown ones so on and the rest yeah
yeah makes sense as a list because there
would be no key
that's possible let's ponder it
so that we can make that work
um
yeah I mean that's unambiguous at least
all right I have to go
see you guys soon
bye all right sounds good thanks
everyone bye bye